هل ستشكل الكره السعوديه خطرا على الكره
الاوروبيه مع الوقت مساء الخير واهلا
وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده من برنامجكم بعد
الصافره معي انا عبيدنا
[موسيقى]
هذا السؤال اللي سالناه ببدايه الحلقه هو
السؤال اللي محيرني شوي قبل فتره بسيطه
يعني قبل اشهر كنا عم نحكي انه السعوديه
بدات تنافس او الدوله السعودي بدا ينافس
الدوري الامريكي بانه يكون وجهه اللاعبين
اللي ختموا مسيرتهم باوروبا وناوين
يعتزلوا ويطلعوا شويه مصاري حلوين قبل
الاعتزال ولكن بعد يوم من قرار التخصيص
الاستثمار والتخصيص عفوا في السعوديه وهو
خصخصه الانديه السعوديه ونقل ملكيتها
لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه السعودي ونقل
ملكيه بعضها الاخر لشركات مثل اليوم
وارامكو بدانا نرى اخبار جرونيه عن سوق
الانتقالات في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اولا وبدء الاتحاد يعد التعاقد مع مين مع
قائد ريال مدريد مع ثاني اكثر لاعب تسجيلا
في تاريخ ريال مدريد مع اكثر لاعب حقق
القاب في تاريخ ريال مدريد مع برشلونه
طبعا ب 25 لقب مع اللاعب اللي ماخذ الكره
الذهبيه مع اللاعب اللي واصل لنهائي دوري
ابطال اوروبا الموسم الماضي وجايب اللقب
مع فريقه لنصف نهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا
هذا الموسم مع كريم بنزيما كريم بنزيما
بالغ من عمر 35 عاما واللي كان قادر بعد
يعطي موسمين باوروبا ولكنه اختار التوجه
الى السعوديه هون صرنا شويه نفكر انه في
مشروع يبدو اكبر من موضوع الدوري الامريكي
لانه مع مرور الوقت ومرور الساعات بعد
الاعلان عن التعاقد بنزيما صرنا نشوف
اخبار هائله تربط عندي سعوديه بلاعبين
كبار باوروبا مثل كانتي اللي بالمناسبه
يبدو ان الاتحاد اتم الصفقه معه بشكل تام
وكان في كلام ايضا وكان في كلام عن اسماء
كثيره ياسين بونوا الى اخره بعض اللاعب
تقريبا اللاعبين الكبار باوروبا الا
وسمعنا انه الربط بنادي سعودي او الربط
بالانتقال الى نادي سعودي وبالتالي هون
صرت تفكر بيني وبين نفسي ربما الموضوع
يكون اكبر من قصه انه لاعبين معتذرين يجوا
يلعبوا بنادي السعودي وينهوا مسيرتهم ولما
بطرح على هذا السؤال بصير فكر بالمعطيات
اللي امامي وبصير قول انه ممكن احتمال
ممكن يكون المشروع السعودي ليش ما تصير او
ما يصير دوري ابطال اسيا مثلا والدوري
السعودي هو منافس للدوريات الاوروبيه
وبالمناسبه هذا واحد من اهداف
القرار اللي طلع بخصوص الاستثمار والتخصيص
انه يصير الدوري السعودي من اقوى عشره
الدوريات في العالم انه يرفعوا قيمه
الدوري السعودي تقريبا ثمانيه مليار او 8
مليارات ريال سعودي انه يزيدوا ايرادات
الدوري السعودي بنسبه كبيره لواحد فاصل
ثمانيه مليار ريال تقريبا وبالتالي
المشروع كبير جدا على المستوى المالي ولكن
على المستوى الرياضي ايضا ممكن يكون منافس
مع الوقت لاوروبا طيب هل نحن عم نحكي عن
هدف منطقي او عم نحكي عن شيء فعلا ممكن
يصير لحتى نجاوب عن هذا السؤال لازم نشوف
الكره السعوديه الان باي مرحله الكره
السعوديه الان بمرحله انا بحب اسميها
مرحله بناء الارث شو يعني بناء الارث
الكره السعوديه بنات ارثها في اسيا كوحده
من اقوى
الكرات الموجوده باسيا طبعا لانه المنتخب
السعودي محقق كاس اسيا لاكثر من مره
الانديه السعوديه جايبه بطولات دوري ابطال
اسيا بل انه الهلال الفتره الاخيره كان
تقريبا شبه مهيمن على دوري ابطال اسيا
وبالتالي في ارث للسعوديه باسيا ولكن
السعوديه الان عم تبني
عم بتخلي الهلال والنصر والاتحاد والاهلي
تصير انديه معروفه على مستوى العالم وشو
هون او عن شو عم نحكي فعليا عم نحكي عن
انه بعد عشرين سنه مثلا او 15 سنه لما يجي
النصر يتقدم للتعاقد مع لاعب ما في اوروبا
اول شيء راح ينقال عن هذا النادي هذا
النادي اللي لعب فيه كريستيانو رونالدو
الاتحاد هذا النادي اللي لعب فيه كريم
بنزيما الهلال مثلا اذا جابوا لاعب كبير
ان كان ميسي ولا غيره هذا النادي الذي لعب
فيه لاعب الفلاني ولا حتى تبني هذا الارث
بدك وقت واستمراريه طويله يعني بمعنى اخر
لازم انت تجيب لعيبه كبار
حواليهم الهاله الاعلاميه حاليا عم تبنيها
وتستمر بالحفاظ على هؤلاء اللاعبين
وتخليهم ينسجموا مع المجتمع السعودي
ينسجموا مع الكره السعوديه ويكونوا جزء من
المنظومه الكرويه بالسعوديه لحتى يحاولوا
غيرهم ليجي على السعوديه ولحتى تبدا ببناء
هذا الارث عندك سلاحين مهمين جدا مواردك
الماليه اولا وعدم وجود قواعد لعب نظيف
مثل الموجوده باوروبا ثانيه لانه بمواردة
الماليه بتقدر تستخدم اللاعبين وتعطيهم
رواتب عاليه وايضا عدم وجود قواعد اللعب
المال النظيف في اسيا او تطبيقها بالطريقه
المطبقه فيها في اوروبا كمان بتعطيك هامش
حريه ومساحه انك تتحرك فيها وتعطي مبالغ
واجور فلكيه ولنعود للسؤال الرئيسي هل
ممكن انه هذا المشروع مع الوقت ياثر فعلا
على الكره الاوروبيه شوف جواب او الجواب
لهذا السؤال واضح برايي الشخصي في طريقتين
فقط للتاثير على الكره الاوروبيه او ممكن
الكره الاوروبيه تتاثر فيهم بشكل سلبي من
اللي عم تعمل هي حاليا اول خيار هو انه
السعوديه تعدي بقيه دول المنطقه ونصير
نشوف الدوريات الاخرى بالمنطقه وخصوصا
دوريات الخليجيه اللي عندها موارد ماليه
مثل الدوله القطري والدوله الاماراتي عم
يشتغل ويستقطب لاعبين كبار ايضا من اوروبا
هذا الامر اللي راح يخلق حاله من التنافس
وراح يخلي دوري ابطال اسيا مهم جدا ومتابع
بدرجه ربما تكون اقل بقليل من دوري ابطال
اوروبا لانه طبعا دوري ابطال اوروبا هو
البطوله المتابعه بشكل اكبر على مستوى
العالم فلحتى تقدر تبني بطوله منافسه لهاي
البطوله لازم تجتذب نجوم بالمنطقه كلها مش
بس بالسعوديه لحالها لحتى تقدر تبني بطوله
قويه هي دوري ابطال اسيا والناس من حول
العالم تصير التابعه الخيار الثاني هو
الخيار الذي يبدو اكثر جنونا برايه وهو
انه ينلغى شو اسمه دوري ابطال اوروبا ينجح
او تنجح فكر الدوري السوبر الاوروبي دور
السوبر الاوروبي هذا يبطل مقتصر على
اوروبا فقط يصير يدعوا عليه الانديه الثري
الانديه عند لاعبين كبار مثل الاتحاد
والهلال والى اخره لانه هو اصلا فكرته
مبنيه على الايرادات وعلى حقوق البث وعلى
وجود النجوم وما الى ذلك وبالتالي تصير
بطوله دوري سوبر عالميه السعوديه او
الانديه السعوديه تكون جزء منها وبهاي
الحاله بنصير نشوف الانديه السعوديه
منافسه لريال مدريد وبرشلونه وليفربول
والسيتي وغيرهم من الانديه ما عدا ذلك
اعتقد ان الامور صعبه جدا واوروبا صعب
تتاثر بما يحدث في السعوديه لانه بكل
بساطه دوري ابطال اوروبا جادة جدا لكل
اللاعبين الصغار هو حلم كل اللاعبين
الموجودين باوروبا واللي بعدهم عم يبنوا
مسيرتهم او موجودين بالبيك او بقمه
المسيره على كل حال ما يحدث في السعوديه
الان هو مشروع طموح لبناء كره قدم او بناء
منظومه كرويه كرويه قادره انه تجذب العالم
وتزيد الايرادات من خلال زياده حقوق البث
وعقود الرعايه والاهتمام العالمي فيها
ولكن هذه مغامره محفوفه بالمخاطر لانه
شفنا سيناريوهات مشابهه فشلت مع الوقت ان
كان بالصين ولا كان بالهند ولا ان كان حتى
بامريكا اللي امريكا ايضا ما نجحت بانها
تخلي كره القدم اللاعب الشعبيه الاولى على
حساب كره السله الامريكيه وعلى حساب كره
القدم الامريكيه وعلى حساب الفيسبوك هذا
كان كل شيء بحلقه اليوم حتى نلتقي الاسبوع
المقبل كونوا بالف خير